Speaker 1: We now have learned about statements
made by David De Pape, the attacker of Paul
Pelosi, Nancy Pelosi's husband.
And he is straight up admitting what this
was.
This was a politically motivated attack in
which he wanted to, quote, break Nancy Pelosi's
kneecaps so that she would then have to be
wheeled into Congress in a wheelchair, which
would really show Democrats that there are
consequences to their actions.
That's it, folks.
It's just right wing violence.
That's all it is.
It's no.
He was a gay prostitute who was home with
Paul Pelosi, and they were engaged in a lover's
quarrel.
And there's no evidence for any of it.
And we're going to get to that in a moment.
It's just terrorism.
That's all it is.
There's a good Rolling Stone article by Miles
Klee.
Conspiracy Theories About Pelosi Attacker
Debunked by Pelosi attacker.
David Pape told police he planned to take
the House speaker hostage and break her kneecaps
if she lied to him.
That is the bottom line here.
This was a sworn affidavit.
FBI special agent Stephanie Miner, who's a
domestic terrorism specialist, described 42
year old Berkeley man David de Pape told police
he planned to take Speaker Pelosi hostage,
interrogate her and possibly break her kneecaps.
She wasn't home at the time of the invasion,
debate broke through a rear glass door of
the residence with a hammer.
He later used that hammer to beat Paul Pelosi.
He brought zip ties, tape, rope and gloves.
He was going to talk to her.
If she told the truth, he would release her.
If she lied, he would break her neck, pack
kneecaps.
The paper described Pelosi as, quote, leader
of the pack of lies told by the Democratic
Party.
There is nothing, nothing to the right wing
conspiracy theories, which we will delve into
a little bit more.
But think about it.
He is openly telling us why he did it.
It's terrorism.
It's a form of domestic terrorism.
It's violence against our democratically elected
officials.
That's what it is.
And De Pape said to authorities he didn't
flee when Paul Pelosi was able to call 911
because, quote, much like the American founding
fathers with the British, he was fighting
against tyranny without the option of surrender.
Republicans are like, well, he was a gay prostitute.
The papers like, I'm not gay or a prostitute.
I'm just a right winger like you guys.
So maybe it was Antifa, some kind of double
agent, a secret BLM member or whatever.
But of course, none of that would be true.
And meanwhile, Fox News continues to give
the conspiracy theories the benefit of the
doubt as the conspiracy theories are increasingly
debunked.
Fox News has to play more and more coy and
just say it's not really all adding up.
Here's one such clip.
Speaker 2: There are a number of unanswered
questions regarding the case, like who.
Speaker 3: Opened the door for police?
And why did Paul Pelosi allegedly describe
the pope at one point in a conversation with
authorities as a friend?
Speaker 2: And if he wasn't let in?
How did he get up there and break in?
Given the amount of.
Speaker 3: Security in the area.
Speaker 1: Of course, we have most of those
answers already.
And we will talk in more detail about some
of those claims in a moment.
But for now, I want to talk about one of the
other claims that's regularly being made about
this attack.